[Música]
con las dos
la de la lectura fue muy elegante
o dos días
una universidad
el cinturón o al hablar del cerebro
y felicidad
de hecho más pacíficos menos resistentes
de los 12
es decir
desde yo creo que la persona sumamente
enojado
sumamente inconforme conmigo
ah
y ahora qué
qué les ha pasado ya ya
[Música]
el día de los padres
en el día de todo lo que compensaba y
como conectaba con cómo me sentía
segundo falta de habilidad
yo decía siempre no estaba del carro en
vivo
y
en el corazón
ah
[Música]
malamente
conoce
[Música]
feliz
y quería hacer por personas de servicios
terribles
las hermanas tratando de la cultura
y efectiva
la sensación de placer y alegría
realmente pensar
qué triste
i
una vez
el corazón en acción transforma un
diario
[Música]
y llegamos a esos estudios todo lo que
sea mediante
nosotros tenemos personas pasamos a los
seis meses
y le digo yo a tu padre
y más
pero nada
y todavía no no no diciéndome
y si mejor
sí
feliz
lo haría
los hijos de nadie
y no es que estemos solos están estas
personas están estas cosas
[Música]
y ahí
fue mágico y de hecho mi nación
y
y fuerza
y todos los días
al militar yo a todos
la gente
y a mí
en la primera la mejor
según adrià la mitad interior vender
nosotros
pero
y para mí
la actitud es vivir
bueno estamos agradecidos
podemos estar presentes
cuando nos quejamos realmente paso a
paso ya lo podemos cambiar y mañana
ojalá ojalá que suene a pero eso es
relleno y tabaco existe hoy día tenemos
hoy día para sentir hacer personas
increíbles
y la verdad es que yo no
porque yo creo con sinceridad
y dejar atrás
yo siempre digo que hay dos opciones de
vivir los días todos los días
a
llamar y decir lo que es bueno con ella
hola
la tarde a su madre
[Música]
y
[Risas]
luego porque todo
se queda tenemos que sacar a nuestro
sistema los estreses los miedos
tienes una chamba
tienes una presentación
y luego es el estrecho
y que mejor lo eligieron porque
diariamente tiene una mente sana
con una estatura de energía y eso estas
lejanas de todos nosotros yo quiera ver
lo que no es tiempo para vivir esperanza
en día ya ver por flaco uno no tiene que
ver es cómo voy a regido hoy dominado el
cuerpo y aplicables a porque entre nada
al cual envía la mente para estar bien
y es lo que estoy haciendo consumar
continuarlo y converso qué tipo de cosas
expresó cuando barco pasamos hablando
del vecino
para hacer mejor
[Risas]
a 30 segundos que hagan las cosas
hermosas que tienen estos libros donde
el tirón
y lo hizo porque es la puesta del
maquillaje
fuera
los días la gente
siguiente actividad para
si es que seamos agradecidos hagamos una
lista
la cabeza es el paso y yo la energía se
transforma
estudiaba
[Aplausos]
[Música]
todos tienen los ojos porque en su
corazón
sientan y solo los invito agradecer que
tienen hoy día para agradecer lo que se
le pegás traer aquí y no dejes que otros
pensamientos lo que hace falta lo que no
hay no dejes que esté presente en tu
cabeza hoy día sólo agradece y siéntete
real en el perfil contigo la vida que
tienes con tu cuerpo con lo que hay y
agradece muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]